done I thought about you like every day
I just want to be with you
[Music]
oh hey Donna
hey um did you see the school paper
oh yeah field hockey team's going to
stay woohoo
uh oh looks like someone doesn't want to
talk about the new most eligible Viking
look Donna this whole uh
most eligible thing has really taught me
something
um I'm pretty
so
what do you say
like we officially start dating other
people oh I've been waiting for your
permission
and can I stay out past nine please
please
okay as long as you're gonna be cool
when you see me with one two or seven of
Point places juiciest Tomatoes
it's just like old times Eric and Donna
talking about meaningless crap that
affects only them
I've missed it so
the brownies for the new neighbors Eric
yeah yes Mommy
how do I look well you got a little
something right don't touch it
sitting up to keep it like this
well I just hope these new neighbors are
better than the last one that Gus
Griffin was a complete dumbass
oh yeah Neighbors
we were just coming to welcome you
looks like we beat you to the punch any
punch
oh damn
I'm Bob pinciotti this is my daughter
Donna my wife made you'll be over later
her thumbs caught in something right now
well we've all done that
I guess
well I'm Kitty and uh this is red and
this is our son Eric
Eric say hello to Donna
[Music]
wow you're strong Casey we need to talk
I'm a little swamped right now foreplay
I think Donna thinks you love her
and if you don't you shouldn't act like
you do
Who Do You Love police hands up love
police is here
hey all I'm saying is that if you don't
love her just don't be with her okay
because she's a really special person
and someone out there could
really love her someone out there
someone right here
hey Eric what are you doing here he was
just leaving
oh well I gotta go too hey Pennsylvania
love you
oh well I
thank you
okay well I'll uh
I'll see you later
see Foreman
it's just words
you don't have to mean it
if you make her cry
I'm coming right back here to kick your
ass
Eric
the guy even looks like Eric
oh my God Donna
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
I can't believe you came here for me of
course I did Donna
I love you and I have so much to say but
I just
I was so scared that I never feel like
this
I mean
Eric
after last year Donna I
about Casey and all that stuff
I don't care
okay
I just want to be with you
you know all summer I hated California
but now that you're here it's like
amazing
this is the most romantic night in my
whole life
yeah I know me too
I have sand in my crack
too
I was gonna give you this
oh my God is that a yeah
yeah
that's stupid right
and
no
I don't know
what would you have done with it
well I don't know I guess I would have
told you how beautiful you are and it
you mean everything
and then
I would have gone down on one knee
you know like this
I would have taken your hand
and taking the ring
go ahead
and I would have put the ring on your
finger
wow
so uh
so I'll tell you what uh why don't I
just hold on to that until
you know until the real moment comes
sure
or I can hold on to it
okay
yeah
Eric I love you and
I want to be with you forever
yes
that's what I told everyone and
they made me wear the stupid helmet
so um
did we just get I think we did
Tana I love you
we are so stupid I know right
so Donna rehearsal dinner tonight
wedding tomorrow you excited
um actually I'm I'm a little nervous oh
that's just cold feet yeah but here's
the thing whenever anyone's nervous
about marriage everyone says it's just
cold feet but half of all marriages end
in divorce so half those people getting
married should have cold feet
by the time they realize their feet were
right it's too late
too late
how do I know what to do there is no
answer
I can't breathe
how you feel is totally normal a lot of
the guys that I'm dating were nervous
before their weddings but now they're
all happily married
Kitty Eric is over two hours late let's
go home
he's not late Mr Foreman
he didn't show up because he he doesn't
want to marry me hey you don't know that
maybe he's just uh playing hard to get
there
I didn't know that was you
I
I'm sorry I freaked out okay
I tried to talk to you about it but
I couldn't and I
I didn't know what to do
all I knew was that I
don't know I think we were about to make
a huge mistake
yeah I know what you mean
I had a bad feeling too
but here's the difference I stayed
foreign
please forgive me
I don't know
I mean
my mom said I should but
I don't know
listen to me I am so sorry okay whatever
you want to do we'll do okay just just
tell me what to do
we'll figure it out tomorrow
let's get in
really
[Music]
thanks for coming back
come on you let me meet you at the pool
I just want to say
I was beautiful
hey don't you hate me
my daughter stayed home from college for
you she could have had a bright future
sure she wouldn't be president of a
company or anything because she's a gal
but she would have been one hell of a
secretary
look Donna I know you're upset Eric if
you want to break up with me just go
ahead and do it what no
Donna I'm not breaking up with you
really
well did you consider me at all before
you decided to run away to Africa
okay look Donna
the reason I'm doing this
is for us
okay so I can go to college and get a
job you know
so I can deserve you
don't give me that crap you're doing it
for you
Donna when my dad got sick and I had to
stay at home
I thought I'd missed my only chance
but this is it
this is my second chance
and you're always saying how I gotta get
out of this town how I gotta start my
life
and I thought if anyone was going to
support me in this it was going to be
you so good go start it
look I really just don't want to fight
about this
what do you want to do
movie
and then what
um I vote the thing we usually do after
a movie
what's the point of that
I don't know I think that's that's
really its own reward
I think you need to leave
no no I'm not she said get out
I know because I was listening the whole
time
okay fine
still got me cupcake
thanks Dad Happy New Year
Eric
oh I'm sorry I'm late
I caught the last flight out
so uh
awkward
um how are you
good
I start college next week oh
that's awesome yeah
that's what you just came back here for
New Year's Eve
look Donna
when I left I was so
positive
that I was doing the right thing
but now I've been gone so long Eric
things are a lot different now
I know
it's just Donna I thought about you like
every day
and you know what it turns out that um
red was right
I am a dumbass
I don't know
I'm sorry
[Music]
foreign